alright so this election has been
interesting to say the least Jill Stein
uh green party candidate I like Jill
Stein let me let me start by saying that
uh in fact for a long time I wouldn't
tell people this because I tried not to
influence how you vote but I'm in
Massachusetts and I'm voting for Jill
Stein the reason I'm voting for Jill
Stein is not so much because I want her
to win or I think that she's going to be
the best candidate I think it is
important that we have more choices
because we've seen the complete failure
of the duopoly we need to make sure that
the Green Party as well as a libertarian
party get 25 percent this is a safe
state this is Massachusetts there's no
way in hell Donald Trump is going to win
the state there's just no way so my vote
for Jill Stein is going to be completely
irrelevant in the general election but
it should help the Green Party but I
have a problem with just died and i have
a problem with the logic of the Green
Party that's being employed let me start
by playing this first clip Pat if you
would of jill stein at the Town Hall she
had last week Steve are you okay with a
nuclear war I mean how are you going to
feel if we're going to nuclear war six
months from now we could be at a nuclear
war with Russia thanks to Hillary's
foreign policy we've seen what Hilary
can do in Libya Hillary says what she
wants to do okay and in Syria you know
it's important not to drink the kool-aid
don't just be a victim of the propaganda
you really need to look at the track
record here and then make a principled
decision if you decide there's another
clip I'll let it play in this entirety
of her explaining her justification for
this all right here's my problem the
Green Party has and many of their
surrogates and supporters their number
one complaint has been stopped beer
mongering stop making Donald Trump to be
the boogie man because that empowers the
duopoly because if you make Donald Trump
the boogeyman then that means everybody
must support Hillary Clinton um but then
they turn around and engage in their own
type of fear-mongering now we could talk
about whether or not a no-fly zone will
legitimately lead to a hot war with
Russia and whether that hot war with
Russia would lead to a nuclear war
work but clearly there are more steps in
the decision to destroy the earth
mutually assured destruction there are
more steps involved than simply saying
if you vote for Hillary she's going to
it she wants to have a nuclear war and
she actually uses his language like
Hillary she wants a nucleus she's gonna
slip very quickly into a nuclear war how
do you engage in fear mongering when
you've been telling everyone not to fear
monger I don't know how that works
matpat what do you what do you think it
looks like you're going to go with jill
stein no matter what at this point yeah
really what we need in this country is
some sort of ranking voting system where
you maybe would put Jill Stein number
one Hillary Clinton number two so if
Jill Stein honor own is not able to have
enough votes to to win YUM then your
your vote would go to Hillary Clinton
the next person on the list yeah because
a lot of people are afraid to vote for
third-party candidates because they feel
like they're just throwing their vote
away but really we have to get to a
point where people are able to vote
their conscience yeah absolutely and I
think people should right I I don't try
to influence anyone on your voting
decision not on my show not ever I
because it's a personal decision here's
a logical problem I having with this if
you really believe Jill Stein Jill Stein
if you really believe that Hillary
Clinton is going to take us into a
nuclear war how could you sit by and
allow Hillary Clinton to win by not
taking your voters to support Donald
Trump because if you genuinely believe
that the Hillary Clinton is going to end
the world I mean nuclear war is the end
of the world why are you even in this
race like you should take every single
one of your voters and give them over to
Donald Trump because if she says in this
next clip Donald Trump he may be a lot
of things but he's not really a person
who's going to take us into nuclear war
in other words Donald Trump is the
lesser of two evils play that clip for
me one last point which is this that
it's now Hillary Clinton who wants to
start an air war with Russia over Syria
by calling for a no-fly zone we have two
thousand nuclear missiles on
hair-trigger alert and Mikhail Gorbachev
the former premier of the Soviet Union
is saying we are closer to a nuclear war
then we have
been under Hillary Clinton we could
slide into nuclear war very quickly from
her declared policy in Syria so I won't
sleep well at night if Donald Trump is
elected but I sure won't sleep well at
night if Hillary Clinton is elected
fortunately we have another choice other
than these two candidates who are both
promoting lethal policies but on the
issue of war and nuclear weapons and the
potential for nuclear war is actually
Hillary's policies which are much
scarier than Donald Trump so bad this is
my thing if if I told you Hillary
Clinton is one hundred percent
guaranteed to take us to nuclear war are
you going to quote unquote waste your
vote with Jill Stein or will you vote
for Donald Trump to make sure the
Hillary Clinton doesn't get anywhere
near the White House it's not a fair
question but that's kind of what's been
set up here I'm not sure if I'm going to
answer it directly but this whole
election has been framed sort of as a
lesser of two evils and Jill Stein is
trying to say that Hillary Clinton is
the more evil of the two because that's
gonna benefit herb that's gonna bring
more votes to her right and it's
interesting how if you look at the lib
libertarian side of things that sail
weld yeah he realizes that you know they
probably doesn't have a chance they're
not getting in the debates his tickets
not going to win and he's taking the
opposite approach he's saying vote for
Hillary it seems giving a wink and a nod
to the fact that we can't allow Donald
Trump to be President so you should run
for office because you're really good at
not answering that question but good
good job least honest about it yeah
you're honest about at least that's all
the more reason for you to run for
office but but here's the thing they
have run this entire election on there's
a lot of great I'm let me take a
sidestep here because i have to give
some disclaimers there are a lot of good
things about the green party platform
that i like i 100% believe that you
should vote your conscience you
shouldn't be pressured into voting for
anyone that you don't want to vote for
that being said if this entire campaign
has been about don't vote for the lesser
two evils how do you then turn around
and try to convince progressives that
Hillary is the greater to evil you can't
evils you cannot simultaneously be
appalled with fear mongering and then
engage in fear mongering and then you
can't simultaneously reject the lesser
of two evils 'um and then embrace it
there's a tweet by uh ajumma Barack
that really set me down this path if you
want to share that on the screen he said
he shared this article why Hillary
Clinton is more dangerous than Donald
Trump here's my thing if that's what you
generally genuinely believe then why are
you telling everyone else to reject the
lesser of two evils when you're engaging
in it right there so it's just a logical
thing that really it's it's it's kind of
a level of hypocrisy to that they are
trying to be the beneficiary of the
rejection of two evils while
simultaneously using the rejection of
two evils to their benefit and if we are
going to be a principal party if we're
going to be a principal people and and
stand based on logic then we have to be
genuine in this and and not engage in
the very thing we're telling people not
to engage themselves in so again all of
that to say I'm sorry is just something
that obviously you can tell bothers me
but you know it's it's the level of
hypocrisy unfortunately my job on my
show what I do every night is I I call
out BS when I CBS I call out hypocrisy
when I see it even when it's coming from
a candidate that I support I am voting
for jill stein if I was in a in a swing
state I would not I don't know if I
could say that I because to me I do
believe that Trump is the greater evil
but I'm in Massachusetts so Jill Stein I
want the Green Party to get five percent
and that's why I'm supporting her but
when BS comes my wavepad I've got to
call it yeah it seems like you're more
voting for the Green Party than Jill
Stein in particular if they're able to
get five percent that would guarantee
them a spot on the ballot for the
foreseeable future yeah yeah I mean
that's and I think more choices what we
need in our democracy because of the
failure of the duopoly the failure of
the ruling class we need more choices
and we need America to be exposed to
more choices so yeah that's absolutely
right you said it better than I did I'm
supporting the Green Party in
Massachusetts because I can do so
without helping Donald Trump but I am
also supporting them because we need
more choices in our American democracy